- 70 percent of the audience stood up.
(intense music)
Hey!
You got your perspective.
(intense music)
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(funk music)
- [DRock] Remember you wanted to talk
about family businesses
a little while ago?
- Mm-hmm.
- [DRock] Did your dad ever do what you do
where you take off these
seven weeks of the year?
No, right?
- No.
- [DRock] So that was kind of your solve
for the whole balance of life and work?
- You know, I mean, honestly
I don't judge my dad.
I don't think I'm
overcompensating for the-
I mean the fact of the matter is,
and this is just so insane,
literally yesterday, yesterday, spending
the day with my family and kids,
on a weekday,
was more weekdays spent with my kids
than my dad spent with us
until I was 16 years old.
(laughs)
- [DRock] (mumbles)
- So now, at the same token,
my dad, you know,
somewhere around seventh or eighth grade,
my dad started coming home
at seven instead of like 10.
I don't do that Monday through Fridays.
So you know, I mean,
I think ultimately
work-life balance
and with family businesses
as we start, you know,
spending a lot of time on parenting,
as we start thinking about,
as I'm trying, you know I think,
a lot of times people are like
"Gary tell me things
that don't come natural."
I'm like "Sure. Things don't
come natural to me either."
I don't naturally, you know, all the time
think of family business stuff
from my content standpoint,
which is what I'm trying
to do for a living,
but it's popped up once in a while.
Same way that once in
a blue moon in January,
you go out to the gym.
Some days you decide to be
positive instead of negative.
Once in a while you work 12 hours a day.
So once in a while I think of something
about family businesses
and I talk about it,
but right now what we're doing,
and this is very meta of a video,
is I'm trying to be thoughtful of like,
hey this is a subject
matter that really matters.
There are tens of millions
of people in family businesses.
Hundreds of millions,
hundreds of millions across the world
that are gonna be able to, you know,
that I'm gonna be able to add
my two cents whether they're, you know.
I think they'll be good, but
they're just my two cents
but taking it out of
the meta conversation,
of what we're doing here,
which I think is important,
I think there's a way for
me to be more thoughtful.
Actually I'm gonna do it right now.
Another thing, what's
good about vacations is,
there's this whole notion of
breaking the fourth wall.
Google it if you don't understand it.
So many of you ask me so many questions.
The answer's always Google it.
(laughs)
Jesus.
- [DRock] (mumbles) Hop on YouTube.
- You know, what does he mean by that?
You know, what are the Joneses?
Google that shit, baby.
If you can't Google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
I think I can do a better job of
breaking my own fourth wall
and explaining what I'm
doing in real time within it.
What I'm doing right now is,
I'm trying to forcefully, consciously,
recognize that one of the great pillars
that I could be speaking to is
family business dynamics.
Me and my dad and then me and my brother
have architected two very
successful family businesses.
I had a lot of tough days
growing up with my dad.
I had some, not, very
infrequent with my brother.
I'm sure they have
something to say about it.
But most of all, like anything else,
I have no interest in
being a focus group of one.
My experiences aren't your experiences.
I think what I've had the luxury of is
I've been out and about
for the last decade,
and especially the last
three or four years,
especially the last two years,
have consumed just an enormous
amount of conversations
with people from all angles.
Dad: Son is lazy.
Mom: Daughter is lazy.
Daughter: Mom won't let her do anything.
Daughter: Dad won't let her do anything.
Son: Mom won't let him do anything.
Son: Dad won't let them do anything.
Lazy, entitled, ownership.
You know, there's a lot there.
Parents want kids to do certain things,
but don't recognize they have options,
and if they don't give
them freedom to do shit,
well, then, that's not gonna be exciting.
It's gonna be worse than
doing something else.
Kids come in at 22,
think that they got good grades in school
and that means something.
After their parents have
been bleeding from their face
15 hours a day for 23 years,
and they walk in like they own
own the business,
and that's laughable.
Parents want to navigate
and respect employees
that have been there
for 7, 9, 13, 22 years,
and not let little Sally come in
and just be the CEO from day one.
They have to balance that.
Sally has to have empathy that
employees have been there for 22 years
and have helped.
How do you think you went
on that spring break, Sally?
Not only on the back of your parents,
but on the back of Carl,
who's been the manager for 16 years.
So when you walk in day one,
don't be a dick,
'cause that's how you got
to funnel beer in Daytona.
You know? Instead of working.
There's a lot of dynamics,
I've got a lot of thoughts.
I'm excited about talking
about family business.
Nonetheless, back to the
regularly scheduled programs.
I don't know, maybe subconsciously,
it's an overcorrection, but
I don't, I just wanna
spend time with them.
- [DRock] Yeah, like
going more for the whole.
You know, you saw your dad
less than your kids are seeing you.
But your kids are not seeing you
as much as other people are
seeing their kids.
Meaning that...
- Yeah.
Net volume of time?
- [DRock] Net volume.
I feel like you have been off
the last few weeks,
like really off.
You've been with your family,
you've been spending real time with them.
- Yes, but I've also been
very on to all of sudden, miraculously
deciding I need to be in
the baseball card business.
- [DRock] (laughs)
- One thing I never want to do is
bullshit the audience,
yes, I'm spending time with the family,
which is amazing, but
my mind is wired a certain way
and just like when the kids are eating or
playing with each other and don't want us,
it's not in my DNA to just lay there
and listen to Elton John
or Skippa the Flippa.
It's in my DNA to do something businessy
that doesn't have the pressures of
the business that I'm running.
So, the thought process of
really upping my game
in my flipping content.
I really had a breakthrough,
it's funny I'm here in Orlando,
in D.C., which I spoke last week.
I really had a breakthrough.
I asked the audience,
there was a lot of people there,
how many people want to
make $100,000 a year.
And I really got them to that honest place
where people weren't trying to showboat,
70 percent of the audience stood up.
Seventy.
So I was like, "Okay, cool.
"Now we're in an authentic conversation.
"Enough this million
dollar or bust, you know?"
And I was like, "Fuck, man,
"the flip game is real.
"I can get you to 100.
"I can get you to 100
with Craigslist and LetGo
"and Etsy and Ebay."
And though so many people want me
to make the content that helps,
I'm looking at Lexus right now,
and Nike and DKNY and
Coach and New Balance
and Steve Madden, this is perfect.
All these brands,
and about social media and marketing
and things of that nature,
I'd be lying if I didn't say
I was so drawn to,
I'm very into my roots.
I'm very into it.
I just also know I can do it.
I know, I know.
It's not glamorous,
it doesn't seem like this remarkable,
I'm not a genius,
I'm not a maven,
but I know that I can walk
into that Tommy Hilfiger
right there.
And zoom it DRock, don't be a dick.
There you go.
I know I could walk into that
Tommy Hilfiger outlet store,
I know that I could search
things on completed auction,
completed auctions, not listing price.
A lot of people look at
what it's listed for,
doesn't mean they sold it for,
completed auction price.
- [DRock] Make money?
- Make money.
- [DRock] The 2017 flip challenge
really helped people.
- The 2017 flip challenge helped people,
I didn't do a 2018 one.
But I think 2019 will
be the year of the flip.
I literally think, I'm
very passionate about it.
And we're definitely
filming this garage sale
for Saturday,
and you're gonna kill it.
And then the sports card unpacking thing.
- [Drock] I think that's fun because
when people I talk to
or that I've talked to
about the 2017 flip challenge,
it's not that they (garbled)
You learn this deal of
like Amazon (garbled)
and they buy stuff from China,
and now they're building
a business off of that.
- Of course, brother.
Who do you think I am?
I'm going to buy the New York Jets
for billions of dollars
on the back of flipping sports cards.
You have to learn.
This is a step-by-step game.
Everybody tries to get.
If I said to somebody, "You're
going to win Wimbledon,"
and they have never played tennis,
they think that's ludicrous.
Somehow, though, people think from zero,
never having a business in their life,
have always been a student or an employee,
that on the motivation of
one of my fucking videos,
that they're going to build
a million dollar business
the next day.
- [DRock] (garbled)
- A million dollar b-,
making a million dollars,
forget about even revenue,
making a million dollars is like
winning fucking a tennis tournament,
getting to the quarter
finals of Wimbledon cold.
Are you gonna really do
that, Carl in Jacksonville?
Carl, are you gonna really
just pick up a racket
and win fucking Wimbledon?
Same thing of like,
"Okay, now I'm motivated,
"now I'm gonna do a business."
Yes, you should, but
why don't we take one step at a time?
And if you're,
and the reason people don't is because
they're 39 and they think it's over,
and I'm like, being happy at 52
is really interesting for 36 years.
I just don't,
the utter lack of practicality
is remarkable.
The inability to contextualize time
is the great vulnerability of so many.
I've never been more passionate
that kids need to go high-risk,
high-reward 20 to 30.
I've never been more passionate that
a 47-year-old single parent
with a job and debt and child support
and all this stuff,
can do so much from 7pm to 2,
we are not taking
advantage of the long tail
of the Internet,
because of lack of education
of what the opportunity actually is
and the lack of patience
and it's just dramatically easier
to dwell and complain and point fingers
than it is to eat the shit to do it.
It's absolutely like exercise.
It's a hell of a lot easier
to buy miracle pills than
to eat right for a year
and do the right exercises.
It's not super complicated.
It's outrageously obvious.
Are we sitting in unusual traffic
or are we gonna be okay?
- [Driver] Car fire up here, I think.
So not in the good category,
but we should be past it soon.
- And still make our time?
- [Driver] Yeah.
- Okay good.
- [DRock] That's another thing I've been,
you really hate being late.
It's so fun to watch that.
I feel like people might
think you're in here,
but, I love that about you.
You really fucking hate being late.
- I don't value my time
more than somebody else's,
and, even more than that,
I would hate for somebody to think that.
They're like the two
most evil things for me.
You know what I really dislike?
Something I really gotta
do a better job with,
is when I have to cancel on somebody
two or three or four times,
just the sheer nature
of my life right now.
We need a better system.
(thumping music)